[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: NOT EVERYONE SHARES
THAT OPINION.
PRESIDENTIAL PRECEDENT MIKE
HUCKABEE HAD SOMEONE TO SAY
ABOUT TRANSGENDER PEOPLE.
>> I WISH SOMEONE IN HIGH SCHOOL
WOULD OF TOLD ME IT WAS OKAY TO
FEEL LIKE A WOMAN WHEN IT CAME
TIME TO TAKE SHOWERS IN  P.E.
I WOULD OF FOUND MY FEMININE
SIDE AND SAID, COACH, I WOULD
RATHER SHOWER WITH THE GIRLS
TODAY.
>> Larry: HA, HA, HA. MIKE
HUCKABEE, EVERYBODY.
LET'S ALL LAUGH BUT WE'RE REALLY
AGREEING WE CONDEMN THIS
LIFESTYLE. WHAT WAS HIS BOOK
AGAIN?
OH YA GOD, GUNS, GRITS, GRAVY
AND GO [BEEP] YOURSELF.
ALRIGHT.
MIKE HUCKABEE, IF YOU WANT TO
MAKE JOKES BE CAREFUL YOU'RE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT. YOUR
OPPONENTS MIGHT USE YOUR
SO CALLED JOKE AS AN AD
>> MIKE HUCKABEE WANTS TO BE
YOUR PRESIDENT.
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE HE
WANTS.
>> I THINK I WOULD RATHER SHOWER
WITH THE GIRLS.
>> DOES HE HAVE FAMILY VALUES OR
DOES HE VALUE YOUR FAMILY?
>> HIGH SCHOOL GIRLS, SHOWER
WITH THE GIRLS, TODAY, TODAY,
TODAY.
>> WHEN THE PHONE GOES
UNANSWERED AT 3 A.M. IS IT
BECAUSE YOUR PRESIDENT CAN'T
HEAR IT RINGING OVER THE SHOWER.
>> HIGH SCHOOL GIRLS TODAY.
I THINK I WOULD RATHER SHOWER
WITH THE GIRLS.
>> MIKE HUCKABEE LOVES TO
SHOWER.
BUT HE'S ANYTHING BUT CLEAN.
>> PAID FOR BY VETERANS WHO
DON'T WANT THEIR DAUGHTERS
SHOWERING WITH MIKE HUCKABEE
[ APPLAUSE ]